[Music]
the golden knights continued their hot
start to the season with a 5-2 victory
over
arizona last night we now prepare for
the first road trip john treats joining
us in studio
with more on the best team in hockey
john you speak facts
kirsten all the vote predicting
specialists on cable news operating on
six cans of red bull and a craving for
suspense
are saying the race for the nhl west is
too early to call
but after four games the golden knights
have the anaheim ducks and arizona
coyotes riding the first draft of their
concession speeches
the knights are the only four-note team
in hockey dressed to impress
good as gold knights wasted all of eight
minutes and 30 seconds in the first
period to build a 2-nothing lead against
the coyotes
they did not relent the stars produced
shay theodore mark stone marc-andre
fleury
all in all-star form but that's expected
it's the promising play of young players
like
zach white cloud and teagan colsar the
you know creating a buzz around t-mobile
arena these days the two youngsters in
their early 20s say
it's about having no fear of failure you
kind of go through those plays and you
don't want to
for say mess up but now i play
uh to make those plays and if you know i
mess up it happens and i know i can
um counter those mistakes and and uh
um not necessarily make up for them but
just uh kind of defend
right away and uh keep moving forward
i'm trying to build the rapport with the
coaching staff with my teammates here
you know new to everything here so every
game i can help and chip away and
you know get more get more experience
for myself the better
keegan earned his first nhl point in the
first period with an assist
but that alex petrangelo who got the
goal gave the puck to keegan as a
souvenir even though usually it's the
goal scorer who keeps the puck so
pertangelo seems
to have too many good qualities for one
person i'm looking for flaws kirsten